how he handled covid was good when it
comes to the books that they're being
removed from these schools good when it
comes to saying you can't have kids at
these events good these are good things
clearly in terms of culture War issues
we care about he is doing a good job
when it comes to attracting business and
new residents when it comes to taxes
he's doing a great job don't get me
wrong the Republican legislature in
Florida is probably doing a lot of the
heavy lifting but we like these things
because they matter to us then when it
comes to his terrible team
he can't handle it I am begging that a
Santa's campaign to fire these people so
that I can come out tomorrow and say I'm
on team DeSantis you know before not
gonna happen unless he does yeah and the
thing is too I've been all over the
country I've met with a lot of people
who we need to win over a lot of them
they or they would be more happy to vote
for DeSantis than for Trump at this
point in time they would be they're
they're you know for some reason they
just don't get along with Trump and I
think that look I actually met the
governor